i'm rachel campos-duffy tonight joe
biden is desperate to change the
narrative and he's found the perfect
plan to get the nation's mind off of his
failures in afghanistan
he's not mad at the taliban anymore he's
angry at you or at least the 80 million
americans who haven't been vaccinated
what happened to him being the president
for all americans
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
they're elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19. what more is there to
wait for
what more do you need to see
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
but wait this is the same administration
that promised us last spring that they
would never crush the freedoms of
millions of americans
let me be very clear on this i know
there's been lots of questions
the government is not now nor will we be
supporting a system that requires
americans to carry a credential
there will be no federal vaccinations
database and no federal mandate
requiring everyone to obtain a single
vaccination credential
and the first domino of freedom has
fallen for federal employees and
contractors
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
i've signed another executive order that
will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government do business with us get
vaccinated
and biden's assault on our rights
doesn't stop at the public sector as the
white house is going after private
businesses maybe even your employer
tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
democrats in the media spent four years
calling donald trump a tyrant but what
we just saw from joe biden is more
authoritarian than anything donald trump
ever tried
biden will tell you he's making these
decisions because he cares about the
lives of americans but don't be fooled
on the very same day that the white
house crack down on freedoms and force
millions of americans to undergo a
medical procedure his department of
justice is suing the state of texas and
doing everything it can to support the
murder of untold numbers of unborn
babies the president on the day this
announcement was made in texas the
president made pretty clear to the
department of justice to the department
of homeland health and human services
that they were to do everything they
could to protect a woman's right to
health care a woman's right to choose
just so we're clear here the government
supports your right to choose unless
it's your choice to be unvaccinated the
babylon be summing it up with this tweet
joe biden unveils your body my choice
vaccination program
now this is a phony headline but the
babylon b is satire after all but today
the joke doesn't seem funny because it
feels so true hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else